so our big presentation is a double act
I met Stuart about five hours here but
I'm already very impressed he's a little
math teacher for 25 years out of five
very different schools Bachelor of Arts
demote of educational Cory University
equated systemic education University
camera he's been head of department for
14 years and he's also currently helping
train our pre-service math teachers here
at the University of Sydney and he's led
numerous workshops and variety
organizations he's a co-presenter lorded
Zuba probably doesn't need an
introduction he's currently the head
teacher both city boys but was built and
changed fields after having worked for
20 years as a software developer with
tippet tech but he was inspired by Robin
Williams now I that's not the comedian
Robin Williams but the science presenter
on radio national thank you who helped
us greatly
getting ready for this little
presentation okay just bear with me for
a second okay right I saw they all said
I've I've been a teacher for a long time
25 years in schools for the last few
years I've been wearing many different
hats and one of those hats takes me to
those towns in the green rectangles I've
been there 47 times now to one of those
pounds and the mint over 1200 teachers
from places even lightning rich and I
have a lovely time doing that as a
result of conversations I've had with
those people in my travels I spoke to
Melbourne and we put together a survey
which went out at the end of last year
and we were pleasantly surprised to
receive over a thousand responses to
that survey and we spent many hours
afterwards
discussing analyzing the data and
writing up a 26-page report which you
probably received last week by email if
not it's on the Mansfeld website the
Australian the Australian Association of
mathematics teachers is now recommending
similar surveys to associations all over
Australia so our intention in the next
nine point two five minutes
use your head is to tell you a little
bit about what we wanted to know I've
been a little bit of who and a little
bit of what and a little bit of why is
this so I should mention before we get
too carried away that Norman found this
lovely little icon and when you see that
it distinguishes what distinguishes
between what we know and what we found
and that little icon is our personal
views on certain things right so in my
time as a mathematics teacher I was
lucky when I started teaching in 86
there was a massive shortage of
mathematics teachers and it just seems
to get worse various things have been
tried that is our new definition of what
an ounce of field teacher is and I'm
sure some of you have met our field
teachers in your schools already I've
met several hundred
of them various things have been tried
to address this situation and it would
be lovely if every student had a fully
qualified secondary mathematics teacher
but it probably never did happen and
certainly not happening at the moment
therefore Mansura has recently said what
we believe to be a reasonable benchmark
and that would be that 80% of lessons
dean years 7 8 9 and 10 should be at
least 80 percent should be delivered by
qualified secondary mathematics teachers
but as you might you would have seen if
you've read the report in some parts of
New South Wales we are a long life below
that benchmark alarmingly so especially
in the regional areas and the outer
suburbs of Sydney this one surprised me
and kind of led to the question I asked
Marilyn earlier today about the other
field teachers because what I have
discovered in working with them is that
they actually do bring great qualities
thank you they bring great qualities
from their other subject areas and they
bring good pedagogy what they're telling
me is that the current retraining
courses that are available are not
necessarily right for them and so medve
mesma has recommended here that there
should be two different types of
retraining course so type A and type B
charlie we have type B and for some
people it's just out of the question and
it's not really what they want we're
recommending that there should be a type
a course that really focuses on nuts and
bolts of how to teach algebra to year 7
and have a teacher trigonometry to year
9 and how to do it well that's well
that's one of our recommendations okay
moving right along No
yeah okay so which mathematics courses
at New South Wales students choosing the
first thing we do is we actually asked
our teachers to tell us here's the data
and thing that really came out to us is
there is a big problem in the regions
and remember this is just reported data
from our teachers but effectively what
we've seen is that the extension courses
are dying if not dead in regional New
South Wales which is very worrying it's
an equity issue we think there's a
serious problem I should say there is no
publicly publicly available official
data on regional participation but
Stewart night this is a big concern this
data is there but it's not being made
publicly available and we believe by
having it publicly available it would
actually expose this issue and give it
more prominence and what is publicly
available is the overall participation
in the courses and so here's the chart
we've made general to Natoma creator and
all units we have however done something
different which you do not see in most
presentations we have pulled out in
there to unit in the mathematics - unit
we've pulled out the students who are
also doing extension one so each of
these lines a student is counted on once
and we think this is something really
important for us the data didn't shine
until we actually separated out the
cohorts this is very dramatically
showing the drop in two units whereas if
you just looked at the top line - in a
figure which includes the extension one
students you're not going to see that
big dip because they're at it so we
would argue that when we look at this
people should be looking at
straightening into the different cohorts
of students rather than just the raw
numbers first some really good news
there are lots and lots of students
graduating with calculus there are
20,000 year 12 students every year in
Paris we're doing a great job we're
producing loads of students the
questionings we're in a government we're
hearing from the universities that
students are coming to university
without calculus without stem courses
without what they need president course
but we're saying they're there so
they're not clearly not going into the
courses where people want them to go to
I mean our opinion we don't think enough
focus is being placed on this question
there's a lot of talk about what's
happening about who's not doing too unit
but for us a very interesting question
is one of these people who we are
spending all this effort doing calculus
teaching why aren't they doing the
courses that are struggling to people in
all the community response to our report
nobody focused on this question for us
it's a smoking gun questions a
challenging question why are those
students in your extinction one is
injured do classes why are they not
going into pure science what are more of
them not going into engineering my
question to you is new teachers in
particular what can you do to encourage
more of those students to go into the
stem courses okay so more good news
extension one is think YouTube I'm
relatively stable as Neville pointed out
to us you can see those lines you know
some variation is it's basically stable
so the top end is healthy but as you can
see a very very decline we have lost
three thousand seven hundred to unit
students every year well that's where
right now we're 3,700 students less
that looks like 3,700 less students how
many high schools worth of students is
that that's serious can we have a
hypothesis which is that students who
could do you Trina are choosing general
alright so we asked our teachers what do
you think are a substantial we get it in
a statement in recently a substantial
percentage of students who could do it
I'm not doing it
51% of our 51% of our stamina said they
thought it was true only 34% disagree we
asked for their reasons this one's
probably the biggest work in our survey
recession collect all these test
responses and the reasons if we
summarize them desire to optimize HSC in
HR the difficulty of the tune of course
and the fact that others that students
are attracted to other courses which was
a code word we didn't want to insult our
audience to say many students find nests
or it okay so some more details here is
the types of responses to do with the
agency in a turn
second now notice that these are views
these are teachers views they're not
necessary facts but they're the views of
the teachers the teachers believe that
students are making selections to do
general because the HR we think students
and parents also share these views
whether they're correct or not they are
influencing students that's what we need
to find out um here's a group of reasons
why did I say having adequate
experiences incapable those are things
that we can do here's not a whole bunch
both of them things that we can do other
subjects are more appealing advice for
teachers another big one that Johnny the
same and never give the right advice to
students forty percent of all the
reasons that we've got are things that
you can do something about so being a
very important message from this is yes
there are other structural issues that
we may be concerned
but there's unlock that us as teachers
can do quality teaching matters and it
will make a difference in student
participation
okay hang up if you've been quizzed by
students should I drop to you and I'm
doing - you know that's really hard
should I drop it or shall I keep going
you're not think you've been quizzed
about lots of people it's a tough
question to answer is it not and then
the toughest thing was I would I would
try to convince him to stay but they
would say it's killing my other subjects
how the events of that anyway tough
questions but one of the conversations
is going on now he's about during the
general and the - unit and when I was a
boy but 3:30 2001 were year at the back
of this book there was lots of stats and
then that was suppressed in the absence
of all that information conversations
happen and lately there's been of a
conversation about the comparison of
general and to unit and I'm here to tell
you that here we've got a bunch of
students doing general and what I'm what
people are telling us is that there are
some very capable students during
general now who wouldn't have been there
20 years ago or 15 years ago even ten
years ago and that's making levels job
incredibly difficult one thing that's
going on is people are going back to the
very last School Certificate test and
you can see here I think that the
general students are actually getting
some they are getting somewhat of an
advantage especially these ones up the
top end in the top 10% of that pool I
gave you some advantage in that a star
calculation these are the conversations
that are happening at the moment and and
the candidature has changed anyhow just
a quick thing back in 1997 Barry McGaw
actually recommended that there should
be to a tas an 8 are for people who are
heading towards a humanity it's the
future
and Nate are for people who are heading
towards a stem future and so maybe
that's
we go back to that little future and at
the time the New South Wales government
decided we won't do anything about this
yet
at this stage but maybe it's time you
guys all join this conversation and we
started thinking about the possibility
of two separate indices yeah we better
stop there so we leave we'll leave that
one there because northern and not that
one we'll leave that one there Jordan
believes there are things that we can
all do we all get access to those kids
there are things we can do